There's always more changes
that we wish we could do,
if we just had a little more time.
We're going to leave those
as exercises to you
if you want to keep polishing it up.
For example, for simplicity,
we had all tablet sizes
and orientations,
use the same layout.
However, 7 inch portrait would
actually look better as a one pin UI.
So you can modify your resource folders
to make 7 inch portrait
use the phone layout.
You can also tweak the two pane behavior
so that the today layout is auto selected
when you first launch the app.
Also, this should just say "today"
instead of having the full date.
That way, it'll look more
like the other items.
As you play around with the app,
feel free to make any changes
you think would help improve
the user experience.